irgendwann hat dann sogar angela merkel
gesagt eine situation die im sommer 2015
dürfe sich nicht wiederholen
drei jahre sind seitdem vergangen aber
die europäische union hat bis heute
nicht die lehren aus der
flüchtlingskrise gezogen jetzt tut sich
eine chance auf das zu ändern
womöglich die letzte eigentlich ist die
lage gerade relativ hohe seit 2015
kommen von jahr zu jahr weniger
flüchtlinge über das mittelmeer
aber die lage entwickelt sich sehr
unterschiedlich während in spanien und
in italien in den vergangenen jahren
wieder weniger menschen ankamen
steigende zahlen griechenland so die
folgen sieht man in den lagern auf den
griechischen inseln die zustände dort
sind eine katastrophe
das allein wäre grund genug endlich ein
asylsystem zu schaffen in dem sich die
eu-staaten die verantwortung teilen
hinzu kommt die zahlen können jederzeit
wieder steigen weil der türkische
präsident erdogan es so will
weil die lage in libyen schlagartig
ändert und und wunsch in brüssel
das ist ein bewusst und man arbeitet an
einer lösung warum die chancen dafür
besser stehen als in den vergangenen
jahren und wie diese lösung aussehen
könnte
lesen sie in unserer titelgeschichte
nehmen sie sich ein paar minuten